Hey, John here and a very warm welcome to the weekly top five goals system.
Now this is really exciting and this is specific to the goal setting for the week.
Now why is this important?
Well there's so many benefits to creating goals.
Things like helping your team have more focus and unity.
So we all know we're on the same page, we all know what we're doing, we're all unified
in our energy and our efforts and that feels really satisfying when we do that.
You also have things like tracking how you're going and evaluating or measuring your progress.
Now anything at all that's important, we want to measure it, we want to track it.
You and I would not jump on an airplane if the captain could not track the important
metrics or measurements connected to the safety of that flight.
Because anything at all that's important, you want to measure, you want to track it
and evaluate it.
Now your time, my time, our time and the things that we care about are important.
Therefore we want to track them and we want to evaluate them because it helps us in terms
of feedback.
Let me tell you a bit more about that.
So when it comes to the ESIP model, so most of you watching this, you should be familiar
with this model and the ESIP model allows us to diagnose in more detail and helps us
grow as people and grow as a team how we're doing in terms of culture, in terms of our
beliefs, our purpose, are we clear on our goals, our values, maybe we don't have the
right structures in place and we need help with that, maybe we need great mentoring which
is in the people component and we need some support in that.
So when it comes to our top five weekly goals, when we track and evaluate how we're doing,
the people who are supporting you can help you because they can evaluate more effectively
and then work with the ESIP model to support you even further.
So other benefits for goals are motivation and reflection.
It's so nice to look at, see what you've achieved that week, you can reflect on those
goals, you can reflect on the challenges that you had or maybe the mistakes or the lessons
learned and that can really motivate you and empower you to move forward in the following
weeks.
Now this is an example here of a layout that Joelle has created and Joelle has put this
amazing document together so thank you Joelle and typically how it works is we have a goal
as a team together and then you as an individual will create goals and sub tasks that connect
to the bigger vision of your particular team and their goals for that week and also for
the 90 days which will connect to these weekly goals.
So that's an example of a layout and we'll look at a physical example shortly.
Now as teams, those who are responsible, the team leader is typically responsible for
holding the system in place and keeping the team accountable.
So if you're not a team leader, your team leader really depends on you to support them
in helping the system work and for you to be accountable for it to being working.
Without accountability, now we all just go off in different directions and it's chaos
and we don't want that.
We want to feel unified, we want to feel together so that we can achieve some amazing things
together so accountability and honoring and respecting the system in your team leader
really makes that work.
Without that, it just doesn't work.
It also for the team leader, it also is important for, it helps with communicating goals to
the leadership team.
So someone like myself who is here to support and mentor and oversee the project, it helps
me when I talk with a team leader, I see how everyone's tracking, I see where there's
blockages and my job is to come in whenever I can and provide the support.
It could be emotional support, it could be helping design a system for you or bring in
some other people to support with some training, whatever it may be.
So it helps with the communication there.
It also opens up the atmosphere for sharing and assessing how you're doing because you
can actually look at it together with your team and go, okay, this is what we've been
working on, this is what's working, this is not what's working.
Okay, this is where we had amazing success, this is where we sucked or failed in some
way.
Okay, we can work on that.
So it really opens that up and also allows facilitating collective reflection and alignment
based on feedback.
And again, one of the big components for success in the ESIP model is feedback, which is part
of the people component.
Really important that you love and embrace feedback because that's how you grow.
It's food for you.
So let's look at how do we do these goals.
So now we looked at why it's important, we looked at some of the benefits of it.
Let's look at the implementation of how it's actually done.
Now you typically have a whiteboard of some kind.
Now that could be a software like ClickUp, it could be a WhatsApp group, it could be
a combination of the both.
But ultimately it needs to be something transparent that we can all see and we can all collaborate
together on.
And that helps with motivation and responsibility as we've looked up.
Then there's a check-in that takes place.
Now this can typically take place the day before.
So again, we can work this out.
But in this case, we're looking at as a Monday where the teams come together, they talk about
their goals, they make sure they're all on the same page, both the team goals and individual
goals and then you go from there.
Other options as you can do it at the end of the week, but again, we'll work out what
works well for each of us here and as a team.
And then it also supports us in goal recording.
So we write down the elicited goals on the whiteboard and we upload the task in the project
management tool.
So something again, we're probably going to use ClickUp and it's easier to write while
their brief is being facilitated.
Okay, Poly just had a phone call there.
So recording the goals, uploading them, tracking them, measuring them.
So that all takes place with the recording of the goals.
And then of course, super important part, reviewing at the end of the week.
So we conduct a review with a team member to check the goals accomplished, identify areas
for improvement and so forth.
And again, super, super important part because you're evaluating what's been done or versus
what's been set.
So what were the goals you set, what's been achieved and then that helps us kind of work
out what are the gaps.
And then we repeat and we improve the process.
So let's look at a use case of how this is actually being used.
This is with community angels, our association.
So Joao opens the session at the beginning of the week, team write down the collective
goals together.
Each team member individually writes and representing their own goals, communicates on the WhatsApp.
We'll take a look at that in a moment.
There's transparency with leadership accountability and collective excellence.
On a assessment, how you're doing, identify gaps as we've talked about.
And we go from there.
So let's take a look at what that looks like.
Really simple.
So here's an example of this in action.
It's some weekly goals as a team, what's been done last week, what's happening this week,
and then the individual goals that are written down.
And that one's one of Joao's.
We scroll down a bit further.
We'll see other team members, what they achieved last week and then what they're working on
at the moment.
So there's an example of that in place.
And just to conclude to wrap this up, the top five weekly goals are a powerful tool for
enhancing team focus, accountability and productivity when it's used effectively.
How to achieve that is ensure it's consistent every single week.
All team members, non optional.
We're a team.
We're together.
Super, super important.
Maintain a dedicated space, digital and physical.
Physical is an option, digital for 100% so that we can all see it.
Full goal tracking, seeing how we're doing.
Remembering that if you can't track it, you don't really care about it.
Anyone in any profession who cares about it, who wants to achieve, they measure and they
track what's important.
So that's one part and really open communication.
So you can die a global.
Okay, this is this is working.
This is not working.
This is what we've been happening.
Okay, here's where we're struggling.
Here's where we're growing.
So that's what that part is.
And then you regularly review and adjust the process calibration to fit your team's growing
needs.
So there we have a team.
That's the top five weekly goal setting.
Now again, I'll finish by saying this is so important because anyone who achieves anything
has clear goals.
They write them down.
They measure them down.
And this allows us to fulfill the talent inside of us, the energy, the purpose, the spirit,
however you want to think of it, allows us to work with more excellence, to create more
beautiful things that ultimately touch the lives of other people and help make this world
a more special, beautiful place by the things that we're putting our hands to, the things
that we're achieving and the things that we're working on.
And this truly matters.
And goal setting, working on these is a huge part of it.
So thanks for watching.
I hope you enjoyed the presentation and enjoy working on your top five goals.